Chào mừng bạn đến với kênh tin học Đỗ
Bảo Nam blog video ngày hôm nay Đỗ Bảo
Nam blog sẽ chia sẻ với bạn cách gộp ô
trong
us đối với các phiên bản ố khác nhau thì
thao tác để gộp hai hoặc nhiều ô trong ố
đều tương tự
nhau và giả sử ở đây Đỗ bào Nam Block đã
chuẩn bị sẵn một
bảng bây giờ mình sẽ gộp một số ô lại
với
nhau thì trong video này đ B Block sẽ
chia sẻ với bạn hai cách thực hiện cách
thứ nhất đó là thao tác trên thanh
[âm nhạc]
rbol bây giờ giả sử mình sẽ gộp ba cái ô
ở hàng trên cùng này thành một thì các
bước bạn thực hiện như sau bước thứ nhất
bạn Bôi đen các ô cần
gộp sau đó Bước thứ hai bạn Click vào
layout trên
menu và chọn mặc sale ở cái icon
này như vậy mình đã gộp xong ba ô thành
một ví dụ ở đây là thông tin cá nhân
chẳng
hạn tiếp theo mình sẽ chia sẻ sang Cách
thứ hai đó là sử dụng chuột phải ví dụ
bây giờ mình sẽ gộp hai cái ô gần nhau
thành một thì bạn vẫn thực hiện theo hai
bước như sau bước một Bôi đen câu cần
gộp ở đây mình sẽ gộp hai ô thành một do
vậy mình sẽ Bôi đen hai ô
này sau đó Bước thứ hai bạn click chuột
phải và chọn mặc s như vậy bạn cũng đã
gộp hai ô thành một tương tự bây giờ
mình sẽ gộp hai ô ở trong cái cột số thứ
tự và bạn thực hiện hoàn toàn tương
tự và như vậy Mình vừa chia sẻ với bạn
hai cách để gộp ô trong Word và video
của mình sẽ kết thúc tại
đây nếu bạn có những câu hỏi cần được hỗ
trợ bạn hãy comment trực tiếp ở phía
dưới video này Cảm ơn bạn đã theo dõi
video Xin chào và hẹn gặp lại bạn ở các
video tiếp
theo nếu bạn thấy video của mình hay và
hữu ích Bạn hãy nhấp chuột vào like và
chia sẻ video để ủng hộ Đỗ bà Nam Block
đồng thời Nếu bạn chưa đăng ký Kênh Đỗ
bà Nam Block Bạn hãy nhấp chuột vào nút
đăng ký
và chọn hình
chuông nhấp vào tất cả để đăng ký và
nhận thêm các video hữu ích từ Đỗ Bảo
Nam blog Xin cảm ơn các
bạn Ngoài ra bạn có thể tìm kiếm trên
Google với từ khóa Đỗ Bảo Nam
blog và truy cập vào website dobon
blog.com hoặc kênh YouTube Đỗ bàn h blog
để xem thêm các video hữu ích như thủ
thuật máy tính Style pro prer
cách sử dụng các phần mềm như Word Excel
PowerPoint vân vân và bạn có thể truy
cập Website là do bog.com để cập nhật
những bài viết hữu ích mới nhất Cảm ơn
bạn đã theo dõi video Xin chào và hẹn
gặp lại bạn ở các video tiếp theo